Tobias you say you are first and
foremost a screenwriter that you prefer
the comfort of a cup of coffee your
computer screen creating these worlds
how do you know when a script is
finished well emotionally it never is
so I'm very happy that we always set a
date that's the deadline we have to go
because I don't think I could ever get
you know I could never get myself to say
now it's perfect but at a point it
starts to make sense from a production
point of view from a Content point of
view from a storyline point of view and
and when I start to see the logic of the
story it's kind of ready but I do
believe I could polish forever finding
small stuff to change so basically what
we do is we we we years before will
point on a date saying we have to start
shooting at that date and then the whole
machinery just has to go for that and
that helps me to be ready for that date
at least so that we can make a phone
otherwise I would just first of all as
an actor you always want to go for being
presence you don't want to act and the
moment you act I would say whenever I
act in the film you say cut always
because you can see it instantly if
that's design so I would always go and
try my goal for all times is to be
present but but but especially with to
business firms it's it's difficult
because he creates some surroundings
that are so realistic that's why we use
soldiers who have served in Afghanistan
and Iraq so we can keep this nerve and
this realism that that creates a natural
flow flow of carrots and story so I know
as a trained actor what to do and what
not to because these
I have done it between 10 and 15 years
so it's actually a gift and that's the
reason why he in my case he's acting
when I'm acting but it's different with
other actors what do you say to an actor
when you can see that they're in actor
mode how do you is it a look especially
with the two I'm sure it's his body
language yeah it depends it totally
depends with Pulu that I I mean I love
working with this guy I think he's
brilliant I feel extremely little lucky
that I've had the chance to do it three
times and I want to do more and one of
the reasons is that he has an access to
being honest and I can feel it right
away
when Peru is lying yeah I don't call it
acting I call it line so I just tell him
you're lying now yeah you're not here
what you know you're saying lines and I
don't care about those lines the thing
is I do believe that every human being
can walk into a room and detect what's
going on we have that it's like a talent
that boot that we learn from from from
from being in this world and we don't
lose that talent outside the theater we
bring it in so if people on screen start
to be lying acting we detect it right
away and it creates a distance between
the audience on the phone so we try to
get rid of that distance by saying how
would the situation unfold in reality
you wouldn't be so aware of how you sit
and how you treat their coffee exactly
we'll just sit down drink your coffee
and be around yeah let's try to do that
let's try to take a deep breath and just
be here for a while and that's basically
what I tell them just be here
don't say the lines don't remember their
I don't care we can always ask you to
say that line again if we need it but
basically try to understand the
situation breathe and just be here and
that helps everybody because then we can
start to use our talent of reading
people as human beings instead of as
directors and actors
from where you are right now with the
film do you remember a turning point I
know you started out with a short film I
think in 2005 he co-wrote do you know
when you saw that you know your career
was really taking off and was it a
mindset did something a new shift and
that's where things started to build for
you or was it just an accumulation of
work and showing up every day for me
it's very simple we did the we did this
film called ah which was a prison film
in 2009 and then to be is called the di
which is like the BBC of Denmark and he
said I want this guy he's incredible he
should be in this TV series called
Borgen because he could be right for
this bin doctor and I knew that moment
that he would have my back that he
actually thought that I could perform
these different characters and that was
one thing but the second time was when
he called and he said I have an idea and
it was actually when we wanted to do a
wolf them but then you wrote a hijacking
instead and I remember when he said I
want to work with you I know that I
found my director the one that I want to
share my life with I think that but
basically I don't I don't think I have a
career I have a life and that life has
to make sense so when I was really
successful my twins were born and I have
three kids now and everybody's fine and
it gives me the energy to work in this
life but I remember one scene where I
thought okay I now accept the destiny of
me also being a director it was on a
hijacking we were in the office off the
ship pillu had a gun stuck to his back
here and it was just a test we didn't
even we didn't even want to shoot it was
just a camera test how can we cover this
but I could detect that Peter was there
we'd spent now a month on the ship
sailing in these Indian Ocean surrounded
by pirates so it was real and suddenly I
could see pillars here let's just go so
I whispered to her about let's shoot
this and it ended up would you calling
your wife live back and
on satellite phone are stabbing that
line and doing the whole thing and it's
not in the script but you just went
crazy and attacked the parrot hmm and in
doing that you hit your head but I
couldn't see that so I just had and if
you do was on the floor
you know crying he's so great
Wow this is not acting this is real and
then suddenly I could see blood on the
floor okay oh we don't have special
effects right today what the is
going on you know
and I realized that the whole thing from
him attacking the pirate and on was real
he bombed his head and he was finally
open
yeah and there was so much blood all
over the place but I didn't stop it
because you know I thought oh he's so
pleasant and after that I was like okay
I have to take control of being a
director I cannot risk the security of
people let's go let's let's be let's be
professional about this that was cool
that was a cool thing I was amazing
today and it became the midpoint of that
phone